there was a time in your life when you
were a young man before you got into
music yes you were going down that path
let's be honest you have talked about
this in the past you idolize Scarface
and then you had the Epiphany this is
not who I should be idolizing well
absolutely and then it was my mother
that one day I was watching the movie
with her and she lived it with my father
they dealt cocaine they they dibbled and
dabbled in a lot of extracurricular
activities I'd call them entrepreneurs
before their time
different product different startup
companies you know different Angel
Investors yep but she said forget about
Scarface meaning Tony you want to be
Sosa right so in the movie show we said
that she that's that's old money
sophisticated money figured out on how
to grow Tony and not so much are you
good at that life were you a good uh
let's say uh lack of a better word
entrepreneurial entrepreneur were you
good at it or was it like something you
know music music was true My Savior yeah
you know it was I would say perfect
timing at certain things that were going
on
and it could have gone to a certain
level thank God that it didn't I I
statistically definitely would not be
here
especially in Miami being the
the cocaine capital yeah it really is
what it is that's what started Miami's
economy right did you ever have a
cocaine problem no no no no no no never
I was actually born with cocaine in my
blood you know so your mother breastfed
you being a cocaine addict so we did you
have a withdrawal as a child was it
obviously I don't know about I got a
whole lot of energy I'll tell you that
much
unbelievable you were born here in the
United States I was born here right my
father was bringing boats back and forth
from him but I actually lived in a
foster home in Georgia when I was about
I want to say like eight years old
how horrible was that I lost spent and I
was a great family to be honest with you
they really really they really did they
showed me a lot of love and they took
care of me they wanted to adopt me when
my mom heard that [__] she was like oh
I'm coming to see you after my shift is
over the last time you see them last
time I saw him by the way but to that
family thank you so much I appreciate
you how long did you live with the
Foster family I lived with them I want
to say probably like eight months nine
months around them and and they were
good to you and loving very very good to
me do you ever see them anymore you
don't do you know their names
hey I know that the their names but not
at the level that I could recognize them
at this point do you think they were
aware that you are now Pitbull this huge
success I don't know to be honest with
you aren't you curious I mean it would
be great you know Law of Attraction you
never know if I run into him oh speaking
about them watch one way or another
somehow some way we're gonna get
connected but they were great to me and
I did lose Spanish while I was in
Georgia right so then when I came back
is when I started picking it up and then
as a teenager you kind of lose it you
Dibble and Dabble with it but you don't
understand that it's you know your
language because my first language
Spanish right I learned English through
Sesame Street crazy enough yeah wow
oh